so this is just an interview for the
newspaper
I just have a couple of questions mr.
grey will see you now
what was he like he was polite intense
smart really intimidating do you have
any interests outside of work
what about you I'd like to know more
about you there's really not much to
know about me look at me I am hi Jamie
thank you
hey Rob Thanks and so first of all I
want to congratulate you obviously you
are clowns glamour the magazine's
sexiest man of the year there's your
lovely page that's not yours
I'm not yelling it yeah you can keep
that one look at this
take a nice cause a sexy pose for the
glamour what am i holding it up yes
please
perfect well sex is I do
I'm afraid well it's real you know
plethora of looks and um yeah it's a
definition of success forget Golden
Globes Oscars
Yeah right that's what it's all about
very good thank you that's for you and
so fifty shades and you've been asked a
million questions nosed out probably
today and what are you bored of enas no
I'm most I wouldn't say bored in some
way people are asking it but um the one
I'm finding difficult answer is are you
read like a lot who's I got you ready
for this be ready for the madness II
ready for ya question two are you ready
for the attention all that sir stuff
because there actually is no answer I
don't know how to answer it there's not
anything I can do tangibly be ready for
what's going to happen you know yeah
there's a prep school for that no and
you know under you ready for
life-changing and I guess people
recognize you in the street more maybe
that that occurs but my thing is and I
take comfort in the fact that the very
core things in my life and the things
that you know keep me
normal and I mean I would say this
outside of being an actor I mean in
general if I wasn't an actor the things
that I care about most of my family and
my my mates and I've I love you know
both and I've had the same group of
mates since I was a kid and you know
that none of they're not that doesn't
change so essentially those things that
and my answer is I don't think my life
will change because those things don't
well that leads me to my next question
so when you told your mates from home
about you landing this role maybe in the
pub and what did they say
did they laugh no oh my god sort of
varied responses I mean it was kind of
um it was like we had a situation where
when I found out I was doing it within
with within four or five days we moved
to Vancouver
my wife was heavily pregnant so we had
to get out there uh you know before she
couldn't fly anymore and get out there
and have our Canadian baby so there and
then we were filming within four weeks
of that so there wasn't really a lot of
time you know I talked it through with a
few the boys and you know I'll
understand why some of them won't want
to see it but you know some of them are
gonna be supportive too so and we're
loving the bed that you support yes
sporting today and did you grow as sort
of camouflage now that you're gonna be
getting so much attention and in general
would you vote beard or no beard I mean
it'd be kind of a silly move to be to
see it as camouflage no because I'm
doing all this press with it so um you
know I'm gonna be stood there on the red
carpet tonight unless I choose to shave
it in the next few hours um so you know
that wouldn't be much of a trick it's
potentially for another project where I
might need it so I don't shave it off in
case but also I just find it more
comfortable
I don't I'm it it's it's bred out of
laziness
I don't enjoy the act of Shaving I find
it really tedious and I'm I don't
understand how you guys doing every day
and so what are you gonna do about DIY
now we're quite worried will you ever go
to B&Q ever again um I love going to B&Q
I love it cuz you end up coming
of stuff you know that you don't go in
for which I find an interest yeah I mean
look I'm not gonna be in there you're
looking for cable ties and rope and
those things unless I need them
fret enough for those purposes but you
know what I mean um you know uh but IIT
I hope I don't end up not being able to
go there because um I do love a good DIY
shop although I'm awful at DIY and and
did you receive any advice from friends
who have been in a similar franchise
like a films sort of similar and dealing
with all the attention um I think it's
great I mean I've great very close actor
friends who are all um you know for the
most part in a good place in their life
professionally and personally for most
of them and uh you know it is good to
draw on that we all do that we all talk
to each other about work a lot and a
very non-competitive way and that's
really nice thing about it I think I've
siphoned out and picked up the good guys
I love the group and um yeah I mean I
talked to a couple of guys maybe a
little bit of it stuff like that but you
know essentially it's your decision and
you take you know you take that on
yourself and you you trust your counsel
your agents your wife your friends all
those people to help you make decisions
so what do you owe your success by
exercise control in all things miss
Steele must be really boring
so crazy
I'm capable with you or the hata rough
start in life
you should steer clear I don't do
romance my tastes are very singular
women understand
lighten me then